You've talked about
the need for a vibrant Republican Party.
Yes.
House GOP leader
Kevin McCarthy, he's working the
probably as we speak.
Trying to firm up the votes
he needs to become speaker
if Republicans
do, in fact, take the House.
As somebody who has been speaker
for a combined eight years,
do you think Kevin McCarthy has
what it takes to be speaker of t
Let's just get through the elect
okay? They haven't won yet.
They've been measuring for drape
They've been putting forth an ag
They haven't won it yet.
Let's after we have
the election is
concluded, depending
on who is in the majority.
There'll be
judgments made within their own
in our own parties
as to how we go forward.
It's not up to me to make any ev
of what their possibilities.
You are uniquely qualified
to understand what it takes
to be Speaker of the House.
Yeah, I do. I do.
Does he have it?
No.
Why would I make
a judgment
about something
that may or may not ever happen?
No, I don't think he has it.
But that's up to his own people
to make a decision
as to how
they want to be led or otherwise
What is important, though,
is that this election, it's
been a victory for the people,
for the candidate
who had the courage
to run in the face
of any predictions
for the grassroots people.
The hippies
are volunteers
in politics,
knocking on millions of doors
to get out the vote ever underes
Nancy, I'm a former party chair.
So I'm on the ground.
You have to own the ground.
And owning
the ground took us
to the place that we are
now much closer to victory
than anyone would have predicted
And of course,
our president,
President Biden and President Ob
being out there
to to make people
aware of the importance of this
and that the prospects
for that
we could win
to offset
some of the punditry
that were wedded to the past
and where
we know elections are about the
But I don't
you know,
I don't really get into Republic
caucus politics.
That's that's up to them.
But nonetheless,
we still think
we have a chance to win this.
But nobody would have ever expec
that we would be this.
Well, we expected it, but
in the,
shall we say,
conventional wisdom,
however conventional of us,
how wise it was.
But let me just salute the Senat
This is so such a cause for cele
Chuck Schumer was so correct
when he said it was a victory
for the people and for the count
I personally
know that it's a joy to Harry Re
in heaven as he is that his
his state came through with the
that gave us the majority in the
Madam Speaker,
you told my colleague
Anderson Cooper
that your decision
about whether to stay in the Hou
leadership
will be affected by the attack
on your husband, Paul.
As a human, anybody could unders
that comment
to mean that your wife, who's
dealing with trauma
in your family after that
unbelievable attack.
Another way to look at it
as somebody who's covered you
for a long time
is that maybe you're emboldened
and you feel more
of a responsibility to stay.
Which is it?
Well, the fact is that
any decision to run is about fam
And also my colleagues
and what we want to do is go for
in a very
unified way as we go forward to
for that Congress at hand.
And then after some respite,
get ready for the next election.
I don't want to be I don't I say
to the members, recreate
and recreate are the same
where people have to recreate,
they have to rest.
They have to get ready.
But nonetheless,
a great deal is at stake
because we'll be
in a presidential election.
So my decision will again
be rooted in what the wishes of
and the wishes of my caucus.
But none of
it will be very much considered
until we see
what the outcome of all of this
And there are all kinds of ways
to exert influence.
It just that speaker has awesome
but I will always have influence
Do you intend to make your decis
by the time the leadership elect
are scheduled to take place,
which is November 30th,
Yeah, we have
we have a couple more weeks befo
But you'll make a decision befor
of course.
Well, you know what?
I'm not asking anybody for every
People are campaigning,
and that's a beautiful thing.
And I'm not asking anyone for an
My members are asking me to cons
doing that.
But again,
let's just get through the elect
Your members are so many
and you running the day.
It only so many hours in the day
And we are so
completely focused on our politi
our official time on making sure
that we win
and prepare for the lame duck,
whether it's debt ceiling
or whether it's other legislatio
that is necessary for the people
as we go forward.
So we have a day job, as you do.
I do.
And again,
part of it
is to be the political leader
and to get us the best possible
and then not worrying about my f
but for the future
for the American people.
Nancy Pelosi,
speaker of the House,
appreciate you coming on.
My pleasure. Thank you. Good mor
Thank you.